I am looking for the area of ​​​​the village of
Azovskaya verge of the village council, which means that a
5-kilometer zone around the edge of the warehouse is cordoned off
and people on the site will talk about the reasons for this
church on the day of the heart of
defense and, accordingly, the
commission of inquiry we have data from the hands of the
victims in this case, not a man, a
fragmentation area and 1
in this case, nothing threatens their lives in this case,
happiness is given and the victims
will be given, we will only give
regular information about what is
happening on the command read the clock the
kilometer zone is cordoned off, there is an
eviction of all people who are in
which kilometer zone
we will give more accurate information after
there will be official comments you
are on the spot help I am at the
place of an
ambulance in Africa or the authorities are
fully mobilized enough
to carry out
a decision is made now after
consultation with the leadership of the Crimean
lived on the road, then all trains
coming from the mainland are passenger trains,
respectively, to stop  to the igloo from the
shop to transfer people to buses and
to the nearest bus station will be
organized with help to destroy people,
then the state of affairs is this now we
see an official message they are the heart of
defense the reason for today's
chips was a sabotage in this case we already
understand what is happening with us
more than three thousand people have been evacuated
today  from the first settlements of
Mayskaya, Azovskaya, Dzhankoy district, they
went straight to the place two fires
raised a copter there, detonation
is strong enough that there
are scattered shells in the field unfortunately, that is, somehow,
it will
work for sappers later, so now
we expect the cessation in this case to
detonate ammunition here  you hear
5 next regular girlfriends coming we have already
looked from above the fields you can see something
scattered already, that is, a lot of you are
planning ammunition there are not there
scattered in this case,
single concreting is
taking place over the territory, I’m not ready to say how long
it will take  continue